pouvait-on m'abonner mettez vous à
l'abri on va retrouver avant de
retrouver thomas bonnet un nouvel invité
noah manoir il est ancien policier
éditorialiste pour le média bonjour
alors dites moi que vous inspirent ces
images de tension à barbès lors de cette
manifestation donc interdite par la
préfecture de police manifestation
pouvoir une manifestation en soutien à
la population palestinienne elle était à
prévoir c'est manifeste cette ces
tensions sans doute écouté le lieu déjà
je pense a été délibérément choisi par
les forces de l'ordre puisque je suis
attentif à toutes les images en direct
qui sont disponibles sur votre chaîne
depuis le début de l'après midi et il se
trouve qu'à 16 heures pour une raison
qu'on ignore les crs ont décidé de
bloquer le cortège à barbès précisément
et une commissaire de police donc
prononcé les sommations d'usagé pour
disperser la manifestation donc pourquoi
16 heures
pourquoi à barbès est ce qu'il ya une
volonté de la préfecture de police
justement de générer des incidents
puisque moi j'ai vu qu est ce que j'ai
vu sur les images j'ai pas vu de
débordements jusqu'à ce moment précis
moi j'ai vu des jeunes principalement un
public très jeune très enthousiaste qui
avait justement besoin d'exprimer et de
scander leur solidarité avec le peuple
palestinien et d'un coup pour aider les
onc ont ignore la police a décidé de
faire usage de canons à eau
alors les sommations d'usagé elles ne
sont pas réglementaires au regard de ce
que j'ai vu sur les images la personne
qui les a prononcés n'était pas porteuse
de la ceinture tricolore
il n'y a pas eu de tirs de sommation
puisqu'en principe on a des tirs à blanc
au nombre de trois qui ce qui permet de
réitérer les sommations avant dispersion
du rassemblement
vous voyez il ya quelque chose qui me
laisse assez perplexe sur la façon dont
ce rassemblement a été dispersé et
d'ailleurs les images que vous pouvez
diffuser à l'instant avec votre
correspondant
mais jérôme bonnet le démontre c'est à
dire qu'il était lui qu'est le pardon de
monsieur bonnet oui et était il était au
calme c'est à dire qu'il était en train
de vous parler et lui et les personnes
qui l'environné ont reçu un projectile
lacrymogènes alors que patrie réa par
leur présence ou les lieux qu'ils
étaient certes interdite mais
ne générer aucun problème des troubles à
l'ordre public alors moi je vais vous
donner nos mémoires vais juste vous
interrompre une petite minute on va
retrouver justement notre reporter
thomas bonnet sur place et puis on vous
retrouvera juste après thomas boon est
ce que vous êtes à l'abri et comment ça
se passe maintenant ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus sur la situation
on est de nouveau à l'abri le nuage
s'est un peu dissipée on a reculé et
évidemment tout le monde avait les yeux
embués parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de gaz
lacrymogènes qui ont été tirés je me
trouve avec anis indiqué un manifestant
merci de répondre à nos questions malgré
l'interdiction de la préfecture vous
avez décidé de venir manifester ce que
pouvait m'expliquer pourquoi on a tenu
on a tenu à venir manifester afin
d'exprimer nos idées nos idées qui sont
vraiment sincères nous on est là on veut
à partager un message de paix un message
d'amour on est avec le peuple
palestinien on est contre les
agissements qui sont en train de se
passer actuellement nous on n'est pas là
pour casser on n'est pas là pour abîmer
des choses on est là pour rien faire on
veut marcher de manière pacifique
exprimé vraiment le enfin ce qu'on
ressent et on trouve que c'est pas
normal de réprimer une manifestation de
la sorte honda on se fait attaquer par
les forces de l'ordre
on reçoit des jets de bombes
lacrymogènes alors qu'il y a aucun
agissement yao qu il n'y a aucun
mouvement de black blocks comme comme ça
pouvait être éventuellement être signalé
nous trouve ça vraiment on n'est
vraiment pas d'accord jusqu'à paris ça a
été réprimé alors que dans les autres
villes de france et dans le reste du
monde les marches luc hees a justement
le fait que le fait qu'ils se soient pas
le fait que ce soit pas autorisé à paris
que ce soit autorisée dans d'autres
villes ils ont ils ont ils ont dit ils
ont dit que il s'appuyait notamment sur
ce qui se fait passer en 2014 pourra
justifier le fait d'interdire cette
manifestation qu'est ce que vous
répondez nous nous trouvons trouve pas
ça d'accord à paris il faut une grande
ville grotte démographie donc il ya un
fort concentré de population et on a
besoin de s'exprimer on trouve pas ça
correct qui à paris ce soit interdit
alors comme vous pouvez le voir il n'y a
aucun mouvement il ya au caire et
personnes cas s'il n'y a pas de
mouvements armés
nous on est là on souhaitait jusque là
pfff on souhaite l'amour on est contre
les agissements on n'est pas là pour
pour faire n'importe quoi et comment on
est réprimée on trouve que c'est
vraiment pas normal
on souhaite vraiment que les choses vont
changer nous ce qu'on souhaite de la
part de notre gouvernement nous sommes
français on est là au manifeste on est
avec un message d'amour encore une fois
et de paix on n'est pas là pour casser
on est là pour faire entendre notre voix
on est révolté on est plusieurs on n'est
pas anti si on n'est pas anti juif
on n'est pas anti états on n'est rien du
tout on est citoyen on
on a un message d'amour encore une fois
est arrêté d'écouter voudriez que
emmanuel macron 10 sur cette question on
a vu un communiqué l'elysée cette
semaine parce que la position de la
france aujourd'hui elle vous satisfait
sur le dossier israélo-palestinien dans
la situation de emmanuel macron la
situation des manuels patron on partage
pas enfin ce qu'ils on n'est pas très
d'accord il faut que emmanuel macron la
france est une grande puissance mondiale
à la son rôle à jouer
elle doit intervenir pour cesser les
conflits qui est ce qui se passe en
israël et en palestine
merci beaucoup l'anis d'avoir répondu à
nos questions voilà pour certains
témoignages qui sont ici dans ce cortège
prévenez en direct de barbès donc un
notre reporter qui suit cette
manifestation pour rt france cet après
midi on va retrouver notre invité nos
âmes
anwar ancien policier éditorialiste aux
médias re bonjour est ce que vous pensez
que cette décision d'interdire ce
rassemblement à jouer justement est bien
dans les airs que l'on peut apercevoir à
présent aujourd'hui
évidemment parce qu'en fait il faut
comprendre la position si vous voulez la
diplomatie française depuis en réalité
depuis 1967 ca depuis la guerre de six
jours c'est que avec des épisodes on va
dire de turbulences la france la
politique française est hantée en
réalité la politique intérieure en plus
qu'à et principalement pro-israélienne
c'est à dire que bon on voit bien que
l'est le discours en réalité du miz de
l'intérieur est scandaleux du point de
vue du droit c'est à dire qu'on se base
sur une expérience qui est celle de 2014
et d'ailleurs qui concerne papa rien je
rectifie le propos mais qui concerne
manifestation qui s'est déroulée à
sarcelles et pour interdire en fait la
manifestation qui a eu aujourd'hui
s'appelle tout simplement un procès
d'intention dire que les manifestants
d'aujourd'hui
vous les avez vu son très jeune donc en
2014 et pas forcément l'âge de
manifester c'est pas forcément les mêmes
et le monsieur qu'on vient d'entendre
avant trentaine est quelqu'un de tout à
fait pacifiste avec ses mots
il exprime une position qui est tout à
fait cohérent ses terres que lui il dit
on a besoin d'exprimer justement notre
solidarité et notre indignation quant
aux images justement qui nous
parviennent de ce qui se passe dans la
bande de gaza et sur les territoires
palestiniens celle que c'est pas un
monstre qui vient saccagé paris et comme
le disait votre invité faire des
barbecues halal je ne sais quoi je veux
dire c'est quoi ces expressions c'est
quoi cette façon de considérer les gens
qui ont tout simplement une exclu une
commande et une opinion qui veulent
exprimer par des moyens légaux
en l'occurrence la manifestation de
voies publiques et des manifestations en
faveur en soutien au peuple palestinien
on en a dû partout dans le monde on en a
vu aux états unis en turc et au royaume
uni en afrique du sud
partout ailleurs ça a été autorisé et en
france interdiction de manifester ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire donc on je le
le ministre de l'intérieur dit pour
justifier cette interdiction est
justement il évoqué ces troubles à
l'ordre public en 2014 donc vous le
disiez à sarcelles
est ce que ça montre pas quelque part un
espèce de désaveu sur les capacités de
maintien de l'ordre de l'état français
ça veut dire que là les policiers
français les forces de l'ordre
françaises ne sont pas en capacité de
gérer une manifestation aujourd'hui et
parce qu'on ne peut pas gérer cette
manifestation donc on va interdire
toutes les manifestations qu'on pourra
qu'on sera pas en mesure de gérer alors
je poursuis alors je poursuis mon
raisonnement justement c'est qu'en fait
monsieur norman est en train d'envoyer
un signal aux autorités un signal en
fait de solidarité aux autorités
israéliennes qui sont été d'extrême
droite c'est à dire que le likoud est
pas un parti de gauche si vous voulez
donc globalement on l'a vu avec manuel
valls -qui a qui s'exprimait sur les
réseaux sociaux
une façon non seulement catastrophique 1
je vais pas rappeler les faits il envoie
un bâtiment
palestiniens en feu et on voit ça un
signal de dire un message de soutien
inconditionnel à l'autorité israélienne
et votre invité précédent l'a rappelé et
c'était aujourd'hui en france quand vous
êtes indignés par la situation et que
vous exprimer une sympathie à l'endroit
de la population palestinienne vous êtes
soit du hamas c'est à dire un terroriste
du hamas soit un islamo gauchiste et
qu'il faut revenir un petit peu de
sérieux
j'envie dire sur les le respect
justement de la liberté de l'expression
et des libertés fondamentales en france
dont la liberté de manifester donc ça ça
s'appelle un procès d'intention moi je
pense que le tribunal administratif
pourra facilement à annuler toutes les
décisions qui vont être prises
aujourd'hui sur justement les
verbalisations de manifestants et sur
les interdictions de manifester un ce
sera facilement démonter par juré un
avocat compétent parce que c'est
complètement absurde de se servir
justement d'un problème particulier qui
concernait une situation particulière en
2014 pour en faire une jurisprudence et
interdire toutes les manifestations pro
palestiniennes en 2021
ça n'a absolument aucun sens d'ailleurs
je tiens à vous signaler que quiconque
ose hasard des circonstances c'est moi
fonctionnaires de police du
renseignement qui est annoncé par un
flash ce qu'on appelle un flash la
manifestation de sarcelles en 2014
et cette manifestation avait lieu à
l'initiative de la ligue de défense
juive et non pas à l'initiative des
organisations pro-palestiniennes et
effectivement elles ont dégénéré
pourquoi parce que le dispositif de
maintien de l'ordre
à sarcelles a été sous-estimée par la
ddsp 95 à l'époque à l'appréciation des
services de renseignement et ce sont les
services du 93 qui sont venus en urgence
toutes affaires cessantes pour justement
renforcer le dispositif de façon
improviser donc ça a été justement un
fiasco pour le maintien de l'ordre
à l'époque et effectivement je dirais
que les voyous qui ont brûlé la
synagogue et le nahouri market sont
seuls responsables de leurs actes
d'ailleurs on ne sait même pas s'ils ont
été interpellés à ce jour ou pas et bref
faire ce parallèle entre cette zone est
ce qu'on aperçoit à votre antenne et ce
qui s'est passé en 2014 ça n'a pas de
sens surtout de la bouche d'un ministre
de l'intérieur donc après ce qui a
changé depuis 2014 basse et la
diplomatie c'est à dire l'échiquier
politique international
donc depuis un certain nombre de pays
arabes se sont ralliés justement et ont
normalisé leurs relations avec l'état
d'israël notamment le maroc les émirats
arabes unis et bien d'autres qui ont
rejoint justement la jordanie l'egypte
la turquie et bien d'autres pays qui ont
reconnu la légitimité et l'existence de
l'état d'israël
pourquoi pas mais il faut effectivement
que d'un autre côté la diplomatie
américaine et australienne fasse
quelques efforts justement de
pacification jeudi raids ces zones et de
ce territoire donc que dit le droit
international le retour et l'application
justement des textes de 1967 c'est à
dire un retour justement aux frontières
de 1967 pour permettre une coexistence
entre ces deux peuples c'est à dire le
peuple il serait bien le peuple haïtien
coexistence pacifique sous mandat de
l'onu
noah manoir merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien policier éditorialistes chez le
média merci beaucoup on va retourner du
côté de barbès pour faire un point sur
la situation
tensions toujours aussi palpable sur
place alors pour l'instant on a affaire
à un épisode 2
calme en tout cas donc voilà on a sur
ces images à face à face
cordiale pour l'instant entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants des manifestants
qui continuent de scander des slogans
hostiles à israël et à sa politique à
l'égard des palestiniens on a plusieurs
drapeaux palestiniens également et puis
on remarque qu les manifestants sont
très jeunes
ils sont venus des quatre coins de l'île
de france ces manifestants pour apporter
leur soutien au peuple palestinien
voilà tout à l'heure on a affaire n'a eu
à constater plusieurs tensions des
forces de l'ordre qui ont fait usage de
gaz lacrymogènes et de canons à eau pour
disperser ces manifestants alors le
contexte fait que la manifestation étant
interdite il n'y a pas véritablement de
blocs
plusieurs manifestants sont dispersés
aux quatre coins de ce quartier de
barbès
on va on va revenir en plateau peut-être
pour retrouver nos nouveaux invités
alors nous avons en ligne jacques
benillouche ce journaliste indépendant
et michel rambo essayiste et ancien
ambassadeur de france merci à tous les
deux merci d'être avec nous alors
jacques benillouche est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire un mot d'abord sur la
situation en israël et à gaza
actuellement est ce qu'il ya un espoir
aujourd'hui de désescalade ou est-ce
qu'il faudra attendre plusieurs jours
voire plusieurs semaines
je pense qu'il faut d'abord avant de les
saigner essayé d'expliquer la situation
se reprendre en seconde pour vous
expliquer que nous avons fait l'une d'un
problème israelo israélien un problème
international
le mois de ramadhan le vendredi de
ramadan
la police israélienne a décidé de mettre
des barrages sur le mont du temple
près de là près de la mosquée el aqsa et
puis elle a été décidée
2 d'interdire les marches de ce temple
pour les arabes je comprends et ça ça a
été une erreur
c'est une décision du gouvernement qui a
été condamnée par beaucoup de gens parce
que ça fait 20 ans que le les fêtes se
passe autrement dans la liberté totale
de la part des deux défenses de police
et c'est à ce moment là que on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait des manifestants
qui n'étaient pas contents de cette
décision de police et par la suite on a
le gouvernement a laissé faire
en permettant à des extrémistes
d'extrême droite de ne pas de participer
à ces manifestations à l'intérieur du
moins l accent ou à l'extérieur pour
pouvoir compléter les les troubles vous
savez c'est une affaire purement
israélienne qui étaient là et on a on a
on n'a pas le gouvernement je
j'avoue que je condamne le gouvernement
dans cette affaire
il n'aurait pas dû or il n'y aurait pas
du réchauffé la situation or il habille
besoin de la réchauffer par le parce que
le premier ministre est en difficulté et
était en difficulté il y avait un
gouvernement qu'ils étaient prêts à être
créé avec la participation de deux
partis arabes islamistes
je dis bien partis arabes islamistes qui
devait arriver au pouvoir et bien le
gouvernement actuel natanyahou a créé
cet incident pour empêcher la création
de ce gouvernement
ça c'est purement israélien or que s'est
il passé pour des raisons qu'on ignore
leur hamas a dit je veux venir protéger
et soutenir les populations arabes en
israël ce n'est pas son travail
ce n'est pas sa responsabilité et
qu'at-il fait pour les soutenir
ils envoyaient mille missiles moi j'ai
eu 4 4 alors quatre alertes de chez moi
j'en ai vu tout à l'heure à une heure et
une autre à 1h30 on l'a reçu et s'il au
dessus du toit
donc je pense que
le ramasse s'est comporté dans cette
affaire comme un complice du
gouvernement israélien c'est à dire
qu'il a permis aux gouvernements
israéliens d'empêcher la formation d'une
unité
je dirais nationale ou les arabes
devaient être impliqués et devait
participer
alors là donc c'est pour ça que je dis à
l'heure actuelle pourquoi le ramasse
s'est permis de lancer des missiles
mille missiles
le premier jour aujourd'hui on a là
encore mille qui nous tombe sur la tête
et vous croyez que nous allons même si
nous sommes anti du contre le
gouvernement vous croyez que nous allons
attendre tranquillement d'être détruit
par des miliciens islamistes
donc c'est inadmissible il faut savoir
qui a commencé celui qui a commencé
c'est celui qui a lancé les missiles sur
israël
donc me sers toi on va écouter michel
raimbault
vous êtes d'accord avec jacques
benillouche c'est le hamas avec ses tirs
de roquettes qui a commencé les
hostilités ne suis pas très d'accord
parce que l'histoire n'a pas commencé
dans quinze jours on est content il est
beaucoup plus en tant que ça et toute la
somme je crois qu'il ya une situation
qui pour très très longtemps et une
situation qui ne respecte pas le droit
international et ensuite les
palestiniens leurs droits
je crois qu'ils sont en situation plutôt
victime plutôt basse poisson d'attaquant
et je crois qu'il faut aussi il faut
abandonner l'idée si on veut trouver une
solution que finalement ce qui se passe
et 1 contre le hamas dans le stadiste
et puis en fait c'est tout peuple
palestinien je pense après sur
l'expression politique c'est la sphère
des palestiniens on a expliqué que l'on
pourrait que enfin bon ce mythe c'est
tout autre palestinien qui est considéré
comme une zone qui était occupée et
ensuite qu'il n'est pas traité suivant
le droit international il suivant la
justice on le voit bien à lui et je vais
vous dire
par les faits si vous comme si vous
permettez il faut savoir que dans tous
ces événements la population de
cisjordanie n'a pas bougé il n'y a eu
aucune manifestation de la part des
palestiniens de cisjordanie
pourquoi parce qu'ils savent quelle est
leur altérité ils savent qu'ils gagnent
leur vie en venant traversé tous les
mois cent cinquante mille palestiniens
tiennent travail en lice mardi
or comment expliquez vous monsieur que
les palestiniens de cisjordanie qui sont
eux les vrais palestiniens et pas les
arabes d'israël
pourquoi ils n'ont pas bougé et pourquoi
il ne bouge toujours pas et bien tout
simplement parce qu'il n'approuve pas
les méthodes du ramasse il n'approuve
pas qu'on mette en danger la coexistence
que nous avons toujours eu entre arabes
et juifs et c'est pour ça que donc vous
êtes dans l'erreur et vous maintenez
toujours ce que j'ai réussi je suis
toujours fait remarquer que vous m'avez
interrompu pas je ne vous ai pas
interrompu leur fils cours de laquelle
116 écouter parler tout seul comme ça
vous fait la discussion tout seul
jacques bilirit je suis ce que vous
venez de dire
juste pour vous dire qu à des
affrontements meurtriers ont eu lieu
hier en cisjordanie justement puisque
d'ailleurs onze palestiniens ont perdu
la vie dont il y en a eu des
affrontements hier que depuis six jeux
depuis gb coquimbo je ne sais pas j'ai
pas dis rien pu faire à la même aune
arrivons nous n'avons seront pas le
problème vous les diplomates c'est que
vous parlez toujours ceux du passé si
nous voulons régler le problème
parlons du présent essayons de régler le
problème
comme nous avons essayé de le régler à
l'époque mail à chaque fois vous revenez
sur des problèmes juridiques sur de 1947
à voir elle vous regarde alors
expliquez-moi fond de conditions
d'aujourd'hui pas d'hier dit
d'avant-hier les coudes et je crois que
nous d'être mal placé pour votre peuple
pour parler au nom de ceux qui ne
revendique jamais le passé vous êtes
très très mal placée
mais enfin moi je ne parlais pas du
passé en l'occurrence je parle du
présent est-ce qu'il ya depuis huit ou
quinze jours
et effectivement c'est tout le peuple
les signes qui est en situation
difficile en ce cas ce qui est retiré
prix mais qu'il ne peut pas exprimer ses
droits et qui est traitée peu importe où
il fait partie où c'est le délire appelé
les arabes israéliens qui sont traités
comme des citoyens de deuxième zone
je crois que c'est l'organisation human
rights watch non pas ya 50 ans mais
maintenant qui a accusé israël de mener
une politique d'apartheid où bien des
habitants des territoires dits occupés
qui représentent d'ailleurs plus grand
chose du point de vue de la population
palestinienne puisque je crois que c'est
quelque chose comme 9 ou 10 % de la
palestine historique qui est sous
contrôle ou soupçonne au contrôle
palestinien est formé ensuite israélien
est-ce qu'on peut pas bouger sur s'en
donner la peine demandé la permission à
israël vous dites que les diplomates
parlent toujours du droit international
c'est donc c'est normal parce que paru
il s'occupe du droit international
je vous fais remarquer je n'ai pas du
tout parlé de deux le du passé je pense
qu'il ya suffisamment de gens qui
l'invoquent comme ça pour justifier ils
m'ont pris leurs excès de maintenant
pour ne pas parler du passé
je parle du présent pour le présent y'a
pas il faut pas si on veut régler le
problème et penser à l'avenir comme vous
ne le fait pas parce que vous ne traitez
pas le problème tel qu'il existe je
pense que il faut remarquer qu' il ne
faut pas y ait deux poids deux mesures
quand par le à la fois des arabes
palestiniens et des israéliens
deuxièmement je pense que il n'ya pas de
paix sans justice c'est un ya pas de
justice c'est à dire l'égalité des
droits et d'un de rendre leurs droits
tous les habitants y aura pas de paix et
ensuite pour qu'il y ait une paix
justice
il faut qu'on revienne au droit
international qui n'existe plus qui est
bafouée non pas par les palestiniens
mais par le gouvernement israélien
je ne suis pas seule à maintenir
toujours pas désigné un tir mais vous
verrez bernay saint jean sera beaucoup
développement pour l'instant de votre
part deux par deux de telle ou telle
autre intervenant qui explique que c'est
que tout ça c'est pas vrai que c'est du
baratin
non c'est pas du baratin du je ne parle
même pas de la manifestation de paris je
parle de la situation sur le terrain
daba girerd pas les mettre derrière lui
je pense donc merci de répondre vous
corriger une de vos erreurs
il n'y a pas 10 % d'arabes en
cisjordanie à un mille arabes le transit
non non ne changeait pas le ce que je
veux ce que j'ai dit j'ai arrivée m
l'autorité palestinienne sous contrôle
palestinien
cette annexion en injection et de dison
de grignotage en grignotage des accords
passés ou non passées ou à venir
et bien que l'autorité palestinienne
contre les 10 % du territoire
vous avez intérêt à renouveler votre
documentation là non pas de présentation
elle était très bon et beau jeu si ce
problème là depuis très très longtemps
j'ai une très bonne documentation et
n'arrivent pas à jour que la vôtre si
mal alors permettez-moi un bixi
vous avez tort de dire que la population
arabe n'est pas à elle une ou deux des
cinq 20% des dans les situations et vous
avez le de l'obligation d'accepter dans
certains cas désauté oublier arabe
aujourd'hui 30% de paix et médecins sont
arabes ou aujourd'hui être 50%
les infirmières sont pas rares et si
nous avons vaincu la pandémie
aujourd'hui c'est grâce aux arabes à ce
qu'ils ont collaboré avec israël
ils se sont sentis nationaux avant des
haras c'est tout et c'est été vaccinées
barnard deuxièmement quand vous dites
que il ya vous ne vous vous ne voyez pas
le problème que tous les métiers leurs
poulets aujourd'hui nous avons 4
uniquement d'arabes israéliens
ça on le savait pas il faut enseigner
je vous accuse pas de deux pentes ici ce
ne pas suivre les informations comme il
faut et généraux c'est le rambo comment
est ce qu'on fait pour sortir de cette
crise comment est ce qu'on fait pour à
régler ce conflit qui est vieux
de plus de sept décennies est ce que la
communauté internationale doit taper du
poing sur la table ou pour en quelque
sorte convaincre israël de de faire
israël et l'autorité palestinienne
également de faire plus d'efforts bah
oui je pense la question à
l'international mais pas une communauté
interationale entre guillemets qui est
composé des trois pays occidentaux
membres du conseil de sécurité m
permanent parce que ça c'est une fausse
communauté internationale et elle a une
vision qui est partisane des affaires
uniquement
ils ont le gouvernement israélien et
pour le reste si on a le temps eh bien
on sonne à des préoccupations pour la
population civile palestinienne qu'elle
soit dans les territoires occupés à gaza
ou ou bien comme ça soit hip hop et
danse les citoyens arabes israéliens
alors je ne mélange pas du tout les
données j'ai ma documentation est
parfaitement à jour et je crois que
c'est dans ces conditions là ça
s'appelle le respect du droit vote deux
poids deux mesures on ne peut pas voir
seulement des préoccupations pour la
préoccupante
aulas pour la population civile
palestinienne après avoir justifié
finalement il accusait et justifiait
tout la répression contre les
palestiniens
on ne veulent pas jacques benillouche
oui alors ce que je sais que je vais
justement pour sortir de cette crise est
ce qu on doit se servir des fondations
du passé pour créer un meilleur avenir
je pense qu'il faut il faut laisser
faire les choses entre israël et les
palestiniens
vous devez savoir si aujourd'hui le
ramage se révolte c'est parce que là le
le le procès lui le problème palestinien
a été ignorée par tous les pays arabes
vous savez qu'à 4 paya que vient de
normaliser les relations avec israël
les émirats arabes unis le maroc et le
bar l est et le roméo mal tout
simplement et et ils ont décidé de
laisser de côté le problème palestinien
et ils ont accepté de renouveler les
relations pourquoi parce que le premier
palestinienne avançait pas nous avons un
vieillard de 86 ans qui bloque la
situation pendant 20 ans vous qui êtes
un démocrate
l'ambassadeur vous accepter qu'il n'y
ait pas d'élections dans un pays et
qu'on ne permet pas à la population de
s'exprimer
vous avez trois listes aujourd'hui qui
se présente contre mahmoud abbas
pourquoi pas ce sont des gens
intelligents qui ont compris qu'il faut
faire évoluer le droit
alors on parlait toujours de droit mais
le droit il y en a pas puisque on a un
gouvernement qui n'est pas reconnu qui
n'est pas légal et d'autres comment
voulez vous qu israël négocié si on ne
négocie pas avec un gouvernement légal
alors d'abord que les palestiniens
fassent leur élection comme c'était
prévu éventuellement que leur hamas
gagne c'est son problème et c'est le
problème des palestiniens et à partir de
là nous négocierons moi je suis certain
nous arriverons à négocier et à trouver
une solution si nous sommes tête à tête
si nous faisons intervenir des gens
extérieurs et bien nous n'arriverons pas
par exemple cette manifestation en
france est inadmissible
pourquoi le le problème palestinien doit
être envoyé en france ça ne concerne
même pas les français
c'est un problème palestinien nous ces
manifestations sont saufs sont hors
sujet il faut c'est en faisant ce genre
de manifestation que nous n'arrivons pas
à nous entendre des restants nous sommes
les israéliens sont face aux arabes
ils trouveront une solution comme on l'a
trouvée avec les émirats arabes
comment la trouvez avec le maroc comme
on va le trouver bientôt avec la ramie
ces maudites
il faut que les gens se parlent ce sera
le modelage vous êtes d'accord avec
jacques benillouche ni su il ya une
falsification il me sens des réalités
d'abord il ya d'abord pour pour mettre
une documentation à jour par exemple
gabriel soudain quentin normalise
également l'accord ait mis si je pense
que par contre ce qu'il faut car il ya
quelque chose qui s'impose absolument
on peut pas dire que ça ne concerne pas
la france on voit bien pourquoi ça
concerne tous les pays des vingt-sept
sont dans tous les pays où on pas très
bien pourquoi la france fait exception
si elle fait exception c'est parce
qu'elle peut-être fm davantage deux
poids deux mesures que d'autres pays
européens aux pays occidentaux
c'est
comme ça qu'elle se distingue et c'est
bien dommage d'avoir cette exception
française perd pas contre
je suggérerais loi israël quand même un
truc pour faciliter le règlement de la
situation
c'est peut-être de reprendre les
innombrables résolutions du conseil de
sécurité et l'assemblée générale des
nations unies depuis excusez moi
monsieur
mais je vais être un diplomate il ya un
historien en plus depuis la création de
l'état d'israël toutes ces résolutions
votées par où est ignorée violé
régulièrement systématiquement comme si
elles n'existaient pas à pour un état
qui a été créée par les nations unies
par une résolution des nations unies
je crois que si ces résolutions là
étaient toutes appliquées ou seulement
quelques unes ou les plus importantes
d'entre elles je crois qu'on aurait déjà
fait un énorme propre un énorme progrès
seulement je ne sois pas que ça soit
dans les techniques du gouvernement
israélien dans la geste et de solutions
ici ceux qui soutiennent le gouvernement
israélien je suis d'accord et justin et
moi je suis d'accord et et non je suis
là pour une minute je suis d'accord avec
vous à condition que les arabes aussi
respect les résolution et la résolution
de 1947 qui crée deux états à ce jour
les pays arabes ne l'ont pas accepté
c'est le début des problèmes si les
paysagistes que nous acceptons la
résolution de 1947 qui crée deux états
arabes et juifs côte à côte
eh bien on aura déjà trouvé 80 % de la
solution aux perdants ans hormis sera l
shakes j'ajouterai peut-être un tiers
aussi de la solution qui est de
respecter le statut de jérusalem et de
ne pas voir annexe et 10 ont été faits
disant occuper totalement la ville de
jérusalem qui devait avoir un statut
international de ville sainte
ça ça n'a jamais été respecté ni
peut-être je ne sais pas par les arabes
mais paris et l'israël qui détenait
quand même le voir sa fin merci riche
est michele rambo je rappelle que vous
êtes essayiste et ancien ambassadeur de
france merci à vous également jacques
benillouche
je vous êtes vous êtes journaliste
indépendant basé à tel aviv merci merci
à tous les deux on va prendre la
direction de barbès ans dans le quartier
dans le quartier on va prendre la
direction de barbès oui à paris pour y
retrouver notre reporter thomas bonnet
alors je vois que la situation ne s'est
pas à calmer qu'il y a toujours un gros
nuage de gaz lacrymogène thomas comment
ça se passe sur place
[Musique]
ils viennent de tirer les forces de
l'ordre viennent de tirer à nouveau du
gaz lacrymogène ouais il se trouve juste
là il ya encore des voitures qui
circulent on a croisé une mère avec son
enfant dans une poussette qui se sont
retrouvés au milieu de ce nuage de fumée
c'est vous dire la confusion qui peut
régner ici en fait on se trouve
maintenant au niveau de la porte de
clignancourt on a été les manifestants
émules puisque on est dans ce cortège
ont été repoussées en direction de la
porte de clignancourt et forces de
l'ordre se trouve juste derrière le
nuage dessus mais que vous pouvez
apercevoir derrière moi et on voit les
gens évidemment reculer parce que c'est
insupportable vous le savez très bien de
rester dans ce nuage de gaz lacrymogène
alors on a essayé de parler un peu avec
les manifestants essaient de savoir
pourquoi il avait décidé de se mobiliser
aujourd'hui malgré l'interdiction de la
préfecture alors on a compris que
c'était d'une part pour afficher leur
soutien avec la population dans
palestine nous aussi pour dire aux
autorités françaises que la position de
la france sur ce dossier ne les
satisfait pas du propose d'écouter le
témoignage de ces deux personnes on a
interviewé tout à l'heure
on est avec le peuple palestinien on est
contre les agissements qui sont en train
de se passer actuellement nous on n'est
pas là pour casser on n'est pas là pour
abîmer des choses on est là pour rien
faire on veut marcher de manière
pacifique exprimé vraiment le enfin ce
qu'on ressent et on trouve que c'est pas
normal de réprimer une manifestation de
la sorte on est là on se fait attaquer
par les forces de l'ordre
c'est ce qui se passe en palestine est
une mascarade le ce qui se passe on ne
peut pas faire un état sur les terres
des autres on ne les américains
protègent quelque chose qu'on ne peut
pas le protéger les français protègent
quelque chose on peut pas le protéger
il ya cinq cent mille juifs français qui
seront installés illégalement palestine
il faut leur pays c'est ici c'est en
france est pas là bas ils sont plus en
sécurité en france qu'en palestine
voyez à mesure que le nuage de
lacrymogènes se dissipe il ya des
manifestants qui reviennent vous allez
voir sur ces images ils sont en train de
revenir en cette direction mais il ya
face à eux les forces de l'ordre qui
sont non en dc toujours avec ses deux
camions équipés d'un canon à eau puis
sont entrés en action à deux noms très
nombreuses reprises et voyez que les
manifestants continuent de stationner on
est vraiment au niveau de la porte de
clignancourt
avec donc des moments d'accalmie comme
c'est le cas maintenant et après et
après il ya des moments où il ya un peu
plus de tension avec lorsque les forces
de l'ap temps de disperser la foule
teum abonnés en direct du quartier de
barbès à paris où se déroulent cette
manifestation la rappelle interdite par
la préfecture de police de paris
sur demande de gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur depuis le tout
début d'après midi 14h30 15h heure
française la situation s'est vite tendu
un puisque à des forces de l'ordre des
heurts entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants ont éclaté on va tout de
suite prendre la direction du proche
orient pour y retrouver
eh bien on va retrouver notre
correspondante impôts last year qui se
trouve à la frontière entre gaza et
israël
bonjour merci d'être avec nous paula
vous vous trouvez non loin de la
frontière entre israël et gaza quelle
est la situation sur place de votre côté
la situation est très tendue
vous pouvez peut-être voir derrière moi
de la fumée à l'horizon gaza nous ne
pouvons pas nous approcher davantage du
côté israélien des soldats l'armée
israélienne
juste derrière moi et ils ont bouclé la
zone non déclarés zones unitaire ne
pouvons donc pas nous approcher
davantage alors que je vous attendais
toute une série de requêtes ont été
tirées depuis gaza est l'une d'entre
elles a explosé juste au dessus de yu
elle a été interceptée par le dos me
réfère est alors que nous nous
déplacions dans cette zone devions
régulièrement arrêter la voiture
précipitamment nous réfugier dans le
caniveau
afin d'essayer de me protéger de ces
barrages la situation est extrêmement
tendue et je peux entendre beaucoup de
la distance ce sont l'eau frappe
israéliens sur gaza
et comme je vous donne donc des
roquettes sont tirées en gare maintenant
il serait depuis gaza vers israël là où
je me trouve paul à l'armée israélienne
a frappé aujourd'hui l'immeuble abritant
les bureaux des médias jazeera et
associatives presse l' agence ap qui
s'est dit choqué et horrifié par cette
frappe israélienne
vous pouvez nous dire ce qui s'est passé
précisément est ce qu'il ya eu des
victimes est ce que les locaux étaient
vides
racontez-nous et théo vie heureusement
nuls aucune victime aucun l'armée
israélienne a donné un préavis d'une
vision du bâtiment symbole et le
détruire l'harmonie ralliait mais à ce
bâtiment abrite une abriter leurs
enseignants hamas a dit roger ganée
comme vous l'avez dit les médias
plus tôt dans la semaine israël à
détruire un bâtiment environ 21,15
bureau de presque trouvé mais il sait
elle a défendu une seule tête dix ans
un mal classé et également ses
opérations militaires dans des bâtiments
ou un son à des civils et être des
organes de passe enfin pu se défendre et
de dire qu'israël il s'agit alors qu'en
fait elle a su tisser civile comme le
critère du bâtiment a pu s'entretenir
avec quelles armes israéliennes avancent
la destruction complète sion et du
bâtiment qui est réduit à néant le
propriétaire a demandé si l'armée pour
vous donner un peu plus de temps aux
journalistes afin de récupérer leur
titre mais cela a été refusé
jestin contacts techniques hommage
notamment à gaza et ils mentent cet
équipement il manque de cet audit des
journalistes à gaza ont de plus en plus
de difficultés à trouver l'équipement de
sang sont afin de diffuser ce qui arrive
sur place on dénombre plus d'une
centaine de morts à gaza et près de 1000
blessés depuis le début de la semaine
qu'elle est laide qui est apportée aux
personnes blessés ou déplacés font
également comptabilisé
les 250 bâtiments et les autres ont été
détruits donc effectivement beaucoup de
personnes et fut pour la nuit et petits
d'entre eux se soumit tourné vers
l'agencé des nations unies notamment
dans le nord de la bande de gaza d'après
les nations unies
l'exemple du mal à gérer la situation
ils ont du mal à contacter toutes les
personnes touchées et elle manque de
place l'élu a également déclaré avoir
beaucoup de mal avec la situation
humanitaire à s'assurer que tous les
civils
tous les gazaouis sont mis en sécurité
et que les survivants reçoivent les
soins dont ils ont besoin
alors paul à vous avez pu vous rendre à
ramat gan en banlieue de tel-aviv ville
qui est particulièrement visée par des
tirs quelle est la réalité de la
situation près de tel aviv
trois heures je me trouvais avantage et
je ne sais pas si c'est une chance et
j'en ai trouvé je faisais des cauchemars
à deux puis trois d'entre elles sont
tombées à ramat gan ya juste la très
proche de tel-aviv est celui qui a causé
le plus de dégâts
et quand même joué à des clans les
voitures de cette rue et les vitrines de
toutes les fenêtres
un homme a été blessé quand il met morte
en ambulance le bilan sera là également
j'ai parlé avec l'écho - et des coûts
disent qu'ils ont peur mais qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'en fin des couacs
il est inévitable ce sera fait à mars il
était inévitable
israël
on se retrouve dans ce conflit qui se
préparait depuis longtemps donc à la
frontière comme en cent entre l'israël
et certains de l'autre côté de la
frontière la situation est extrêmement
tendue pour la crs qu'on peut espérer
une désescalade détention dans les jours
à venir ou pas selon vous salut mon
travail en tant que journaliste dans
cette région c'est qu'on n'est que
jamais rien prédire si l'on évoque sur
le terrain une désescalade potentielle
des efforts pour donner notamment des
soins le diplomate égyptien qui a
préparé un cessez le feu entre hamas et
israël qui pourrait avoir une
désescalade à partir de demain dimanche
il sera l explorer essayer de nettoyer
gaza à l'occasion c'est à dire je
détruire autant de plateformes de
lancement de roquettes
autant en milieu occupé par le hamas que
possible cinq ans après son lancement à
gaza ont été détruites et donc
effectivement on commence à parler de
désescalade dans les journées à venir
mais c'est difficile à dire tout ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que la situation
sur le terrain alors ils sont retrouve
un samedi après-midi en général dans la
rue afin de passer au lieu-dit agréable
et bien et tous les magasins sont fermés
et il n'y a personne dans les rues sinon
à part la police les tanks et les
journalistes les gens restent chez eux
ils ont peur pour la cia remercie
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
pour cet éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes à la frontière entre gaza et israël
on va retrouver thomas bonne et on va
reprendre la direction de barbès à paris
un pur et bien faire un point sur la
situation sur place on sait que 4 me
deux cents policiers et gendarmes sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui pour cette
manifestation interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris à la
demande de gérald darmanin le ministre
de l'intérieur qui est bien ce justifié
cette interdiction par des heurts qui
avaient éclaté en 2014 à sarcelles lors
d'une manifestation similaire en soutien
au peuple palestinien alors depuis le
début de cette manifestation avant même
qu'elles commencent les forces de
l'ordre eh bien on tenté de dissuader
les manifestants de venir manifester à
paris puisque les tout premiers
manifestants ont été bien évacuer
rapidement des forces de l'ordre les
forces de l'ordre ont fait usage de gaz
lacrymogène ont fait usage dans déployer
les canons à eau pour tenter de
disperser les manifestants les dissuader
de manifester pourtant ils étaient ils
sont toujours plusieurs centaines voire
plus à manifester leur soutien au peuple
palestinien ils sont nombreux à venir
des quatre coins de l'île de france en
majorité des banlieues beaucoup de
jeunes parmi les cortèges alors parmi le
cortège donc on va retrouver thomas
bonnet pour faire un point qu'en est il
thomas de la situation à ce que les
tensions se sont apaisées ou est ce qu
on est toujours un peu sur le qui vive
on a les tensions qui se sont emparés
véritablement apaisé vous êtes toujours
ce face à face ici entre les crs et les
manifestants on voit les forces de
l'ordre utilisent régulièrement le canon
à eau du des tiers de l bd est également
n'a pu être témoin de tir de l bd en
direction des manifestants qui tentaient
de s'avancer en fait en direction des
forces de l'ordre
toujours ce face à face tendu ici vous
avez non seulement une poignée de
manifestants l'essentiel du cortège est
encore un peu plus loin où on aidait
tout à l'heure donc en direction de la
porte de clignancourt et les forces de
l'ordre pour l'instant n'avance pas on
sent quand même qu'il y à la possibilité
qu'elle charge qui si quelques temps
parce que il ya maintenant un moment
qu'elle songe très sonné ici ou et le
canon à eau qui est utilisé très très
régulièrement pour tenter de disperser
au revoir à tire d'aile vd qui vient
d'être fait à l'instant les personnes
qui ont voix est blessé est parti en
boitant justement à l'instant donc il
vient de recevoir un tir de mbv ici
forces de l'ordre qui sont stationnés
derrière elle il ya beaucoup de renforts
notamment nouvelles et des gendarmes qui
sont qui sont positionnés et donc voilà
pour cette situation toujours aussi
tendue ici on n'est pas très loin de la
porte de clignancourt sur le boulevard
ornano
est ce que les policiers ont appelé
les manifestants
dispersion pas encore elle ce qu'elle va
bientôt se terminer vous pensez qu'ils
vont peut-être bientôt demander
[Musique]
de la manifestation étant interdite en
fait il y à des appels à la dispersion
qui sont prononcés régulièrement avec
des sommations vous participez à un
regroupement qui a été interdite et
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils font
usage de la force ils ont prévenu on a
entendu tout à l'heure notamment en
début de journée en début d'après midi
nous allons faire usage de la force et
depuis bien ça ne s'est pas arrêtée avec
donc c'est ses canons à eau ces gaz
lacrymogène et ses deux soeurs de l bd
qui sont utilisées pour tenter de
disperser la foule mais la foule est
toujours en fait assez compact comme je
le disais à les situer plutôt ici avec
évidemment des personnes qui se
réfugient dans les rues adjacentes pour
échapper au nuage de gaz lacrymogène
échapper aux au canon à eau également on
voit aussi quelques projectiles arrivait
en direction des forces de l'ordre
de temps en temps thomas bonnin en
direct du quartier de barbès où se
déroule la manifestation en soutien au
peuple palestinien aujourd'hui
manifestation interdite par les
autorités
on va tout de suite retrouvé notre
prochaine invité bruno attali les
présidents fondateurs du collectif
touche pas à mon flic
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors quand vous voyez
ces heurts entre manifestants et forces
de l'ordre vous vous dites que le
ministre de l'intérieur avait raison
d'interdire cette manifestation
effectivement il avait raison d'autres
parier aussi eu le tribunal qui s'est
prononcé donc ces voyous ne respectent
pas les lois de la république
donc ce sont les mêmes voyous avec
fillon nous avons pas mal de problèmes
dans les sites et donc sont descendus
pour pour soi disant défendre le peuple
palestinien le peuple palestinien et non
vraiment rien à faire parce que ce
qu'ils peuvent palestiniens c'est le
hamas qui qu'ils les gorges
vous savez le hamas sait comment ont des
fenêtres les homosexuels on lapide les
femmes on égorge les opposants
politiques
on se sert de bouclier humain et on voit
jamais personne dans la rue pour
défendre le peuple palestinien voilà si
c'est pas justement cette interdiction
qui a mis le feu aux poudres
parce que partout ailleurs dans le monde
les manifestants ont été autorisés à
manifester et des manifestations pro
palestiniennes aux états unis en turquie
au royaume uni en afrique du sud
pourquoi pas en france mais en france on
a eu de la vie un rassemblement en mars
elle est conservée dans non à paris non
parce que nos services de renseignement
ont bien travaillé et savent très bien
que ce sont les racailles des cités qui
descendent pour tout casser et il ya
sept ans c'est ce qui s'est passé donc
objectivement toute façon si on
l'interdît icas si on n'interdit pas y
casse donc voilà ce sont des rebelles de
la société ils ont détestation de la
france ils ont détestation d'israël ils
ont une détestation de tout ce qui n'est
pas comme eux donc détestation de la
police et donc c'est tout ce qu'il ya à
faire cesser la répression face à ces
délinquants etc et quelles sont les
stratégies policière mise en place pour
une limite et si je puis dire les
débordements il ya des stratégies
agréable forcément vous savez quoi le
maintien de l'ordre
nous avons des professionnels qui sont
sur le terrain et d'ailleurs bravo à mes
collègues ce qu'il faut vraiment être
patient mais oui effectivement le but
aujourd'hui on nous demande de protéger
l'intégrité physique de l'adversaire
c'est à dire du voyou donc voilà
j'espère qu'on n'aura pas de blessés de
notre côté et s'il ya des blessés en
face et bien il faut les assumer tout
simplement c'est à dire que quand on ne
respecte pas la loi
force reste à la loi et donc il faut
tout simplement disperser ces gens là
par la force d interpeller s'il le faut
les verbaliser de 135 euros et surtout
d'interpeller ceux qui ont organisé
cette manifestation
sachant encore une fois qu'elle était
interdite c'est une difficulté
supplémentaire de faire face à une
manifestation dispersée justement parce
qu'on en a un peu partout des
manifestants au niveau des rues dans
barbès c'est plus compliqué de gérer une
manifestation dit
dispersés qu'un bloc toute façon ce qui
est difficile à gérer ce sont les voyous
c'est à dire que ça soit une
manifestation qui a été légal ou qui ne
l'est pas ce sont les voyous donc vous
avez eu par exemple manifestation pour
sara lee lui il ya un mois au trocadéro
il n'y a pas eu un abribus de casser il
n'y a pas eu un jet de projectiles sur
les forces de l'ordre
donc tout simplement ces gens là sont
des voyous encore une fois se sert de la
cause palestinienne
ils ont rien à faire des palestiniens
les palestiniens comment sont les
victimes du hamas un groupe terroriste
encore une fois qui lapide comment qui
lapide les femmes
donc voilà donc ils n'en ont rien à
faire ce sont des voyous qui veulent
casser qui veulent profiter de la
situation pour bien entraîneur
séparatisme l'a bien montré il répète ce
qu'ils font ce qu'ils font ici ils ne
sont dans les cités tous les jours donc
là c'était une bonne excuse pour venir
casser
j'espère que mes collègues là il ya
quand même pas mal de collègues donc
j'espère que l'on va donner c'est
travailler et pour va nous laisser
interpeller s'il ya de la casse en face
à bale va falloir s'y habituer tout
simplement parce que la casse
aujourd'hui c'est sur les policiers
donc aujourd'hui on aimerait bien que ça
change de camp et d'ailleurs quand on
parle de la peur doit changer de camp je
m'excuse mais ces gens là n'ont pas du
tout peur ça soit l'on voit enlever un
direction aux images voilà il ya une
interdiction de manifester
on se disperse 90% de la population se
comporte bien avec les lois de la
république c'est 10% là il va falloir
faire quelque chose quatre mille deux
cents policiers mobilisés pour cette
manifestation à paris ça ne dispositif
assez assez conséquent oui c'est très
con c'est un très très conséquent pardon
mais tout simplement c'est la
dangerosité de ces gens qui sont sans
foi ni loi
vous voyez une petite racaille quand
même à tuer un policier
comment avignon n'y a pas très longtemps
donc effectivement plus on est nombreux
mieux c est aussi protégé donc les
personnes qui n'ont rien à voir aussi
dans cette situation où et 4200
policiers c'est énorme pour pour ce
nombre de manifestants mais qui sont
extrêmement dangereux et certains sont
capables de tout s'ils peuvent ainsi
permettre au cas où un policier je pense
qu'ils ne se gênerait pas y vont pas se
gêner pardon alors vous parlez de
racailles et 2
voyou je rappelle que vos propos
n'engagent que vous vous pensez pas que
parmi ces manifestants il existe bien
des simples eux de simples français qui
sont là véritablement pour apporter
pacifiquement leur soutien au peuple
palestinien
alors d'abord un an n'enfreint pas la
loi et secundo je voudrais voir ces gens
manifester quand le hamas
comment la pile de des femmes quand le
hamas
comment applique la charia dans ce pays
vous savez par exemple à une centaine de
morts palestiniens sur les ripostes
israéliennes
mais je peux vous dire que sans il ya
bien plus de 100 morts par mois
palestiniens sous les poteaux du hamas a
sauf que ces gens là on ne les voit pas
ce qui les intéresse ce ne sont pas les
victimes palestiniennes peu ce qui les
intéresse c'est la haine de l'israélien
sela haine du français et donc voilà
donc où sont ils ces gens là pendant que
le vous allez sur les réseaux sociaux
vous voyez toutes les palestiniens à qui
on accorder un droit d'asile
il vous le dise que la bande de gaza
c'est un état islamique
c'est à dire que c'est comment ce sont
de vrais terroristes qui opprime un
peuple et donc ces gens là ne sont pas
là ce qui les intéresse c'est israël et
la haine d'israël la haine des juifs
la haine de la police la haine de la
france line du drapeau mais je ne pense
pas qu'ils défendent les palestiniens
mais pas les palestiniens devraient être
défendus par rapport au hamas qui les
oppriment véritablement il n'y a pas de
démocratie
c'est ainsi c'est un peuple qui est
opprimé par le hamas bruno attal merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président
fondateur du collectif touche pas à mon
flic on va retrouver on va retourner à
barbès dans le quartier
dans le quartier de barbès où se déroule
actuellement la manifestation en soutien
au peuple palestinien alors pour
l'instant on a affaire un calme assez
relatif un même si on l'a vu un tout au
long de l'après midi on a aperçu
plusieurs affrontements des heurts entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre des
forces de l'ordre qui ont tout de suite
en avant même le début de cette
manifestation il ya un voulu dissuader
les manifestants de rejoindre le cortège
manifestation interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris on la
rappelle un parent sur demande de gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur qui
évoquait et bien une situation similaire
en 2014 des heurts qui avaient lieu en
ce moment en ce moment main alors cette
édition spéciale sur rt france se
poursuit ce sera d'ici quelques minutes
avec sophie normand couturier en
attendant je vous propose de regarder
ces images de manifestations en soutien
au peuple palestinien
un peu partout dans le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 10h à la guiche et fraîche est soit il
s run et fraîche
[Applaudissements]
à
eva
[Applaudissements]
entre 150 et 200 manifestants réunis à
paris en soutien au peuple palestinien
face à eux et quelques 4000 200
policiers et gendarmes mobilisés canons
à eau et gaz lacrymogènes pour tenter de
disperser les protestataires
la manifestation parisienne a été
interdite par la préfecture de police de
la capitale mais les organisateurs ont
décidé de maintenir leur appel au
rassemblement
on retrouve notre reporter dans un
instant au proche orient les le dernier
bilan des autorités palestiniennes cet
état de 139 morts et 1000 blessés dans
les bombardements israéliens
ce samedi c'est l'immeuble qui abrite
les locaux d'al jazeera et l' agence de
presse américaine associated press qui a
été la cible d'une frappe de salles dans
la bande de gaza affrontements
meurtriers également en cisjordanie
nouveau front de ce conflit qui
s'envenime depuis lundi
300 roquettes ont été lancées par des
groupes armés palestiniens sur le
territoire israélien tuant neuf
personnes et faisant plus de cinq cent
soixante blessés
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france alors que la
situation s'embrase au proche-orient une
trentaine d'associations
pro-palestiniennes ont appelé à
manifester à paris en soutien aux
palestiniens manifestation interdite
hier par la préfecture de police de la
capitale sur demande du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin interdiction
confirmée par le tribunal administratif
de paris saisi par les organisateurs qui
ont malgré tout décidé de maintenir
l'appel au rassemblement vous avez suivi
cette mobilisation parisienne tout au
long de cet après midi des affrontements
ont éclaté entre quelques 200
protestataires et les forces de l'ordre
nous sommes avec notre reporter thomas
bonnin le temps va vous suivez ce
rassemblement parisien depuis le début
d'après-midi face aux manifestants donc
quelques 4000 200 policiers et gendarmes
et un mot d'ordre disperser les
protestataires
quelle est la situation actuellement
thomas
écoutez on est au coeur justement du
dispositif des forces de l'ordre en tout
cas qui a déployé ici à ces endroits là
il avait là le canon à eau qui est en
train de faire une manoeuvre marche
arrière il ya quelques instants on fait
les forces de l'ordre ont chargé en
direction de la foule qui est à une
cinquantaine voire une centaine de
mètres d'ici voyez les gendarmes qui
sont en train de reculer il ya eu
beaucoup de gaz lacrymogène qui a été
tirée de répression de l'action violente
vous l'avez dit le mot d'ordre
aujourd'hui la stratégie c'était donc
d'empêcher tout rassemblement d'empêcher
la formation d'un cortège et quand on
est arrivé en début d'après midi
on a eu d'abord des petits groupes d'une
dizaine voire d'une vingtaine de
personnes qui tentaient de se rassembler
qui me demandaient où était la
manifestation est en fait c'était
compliqué de leur répondre parce qu'il
n'y a pas de vie véritablement de
manifestations il se trouve qu'au cours
de l'après midi
il a finalement plusieurs dizaines de
personnes qui ont réussi à se rassembler
pour former le cortège la foule que vous
voyez que vous avez pu suivre avec nous
tout au long de l'après midi
maintenant on assiste à ce face à face
tendu entre donc les forces de l'ordre
et gendarmes où on se trouve
actuellement il est manifestants qui
sont de l'autre côté qui dressent des
barricades
on a tout à l'heure des projets que s'il
est relancé et en réponse donc le canon
à eau a été utilisée créé largement des
gaz lacrymogènes aussi très largement
alors du côté des manifestants
évidemment on regrette que cette
manifestation était interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris
parce qu'il comptait donc appelé chez
d'une part leur soutien avec le peuple
palestinien et puis d'autre part aussi
faire entendre à emmanuel macron que la
position de la france sur ce dossier ne
leur plaît pas propose d'écouter des
témoignages que nous avons recueillis
tout à l'heure
on est avec le peuple palestinien on est
contre les agissements qui sont en train
de se passer actuellement nous on n'est
pas là pour casser on n'est pas là pour
abîmer des choses on est là pour rien
faire on veut marcher de manière
pacifique exprimé vraiment le enfin ce
qu'on ressent et on trouve que c'est pas
normal de réprimer une manifestation de
la sorte on est là on se fait attaquer
par les forces de l'ordre
c'est ce qui se passe en palestine est
une mascarade le ce qui se passe on ne
peut pas faire un état sur les terres
des autres on nous les américains
prothèse quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
le protéger les français prothèse
quelque chose on peut pas le protéger il
ya cinq cent mille juifs français qui
sont installés illégalement palestine
il faut leur pays c'est ici c'est en
france est pas là bas ils sont plus en
sécurité en france qu'en palestine
alors voilà pendant que pendant que vous
écoutez ces témoignages décision a été
prise de charger à nouveau et du gaz
lacrymogène qui était en train d'être
tirées alors alors je vous parle là on
sent que depuis quelques minutes
maintenant les forces de l'ordre tentent
de disperser véritablement cette
manifestation en direction de la place
de clignancourt la porte de clignancourt
pardon et on voit donc de plus en plus
de charges et de tirs mais la foule en
face certains elle s'éloigne parce qu'il
ya du dénué de fumage dénué de gaz
lacrymogènes mais elle revient dès que
cela se dissipe aura donc eux aussi
aimeraient évidemment ce qui va se
passer maintenant pour cette situation
ici on est au boulevard ornano pas très
loin de la porte de clignancourt syrien
dans moto mac il ya combien de
manifestants qui sont encore présents
dans le quartier de barbès
alors c'est assez compliqué de vous
répondre sophie parce qu'en fait sur la
foule qui se trouve à quelques mètres de
nous je dirais qu'il pourrait y avoir
entre 400 et 500 personnes
il ya aussi des petits groupes qu'on
voit parfois dans les rues
perpendiculaires dans des personnes qui
ont parfois fui les charges vous les
tirs de gaz lacrymogènes ou qu'en fait
c'était assez éparpillés il ya aussi du
monde qui est resté plus barbares baisse
mais pas vraiment de manifestations pas
de cortège il semblerait qu'il soit ici
qu'il est le plus grand nombre de
personnes et voilà à vue de nez je vous
dirais entre 400 et 500 personnes c'est
assez difficile de l'estimé parce que
comme je voulais dix n'ont pas eu de
traces et il n'y a pas eu de cortèges
n'y a pas eu de moment où la
manifestation était complète on assiste
en fait à des manière sporadique à des
regroupements de de manifestants parfois
certains sont violents parfois ils
avancent vers les forces de l'ordre
d'autres sont un peu plus en retrait
voilà pourquoi il est assez compliqué
d'estimer le nombre précis de personnes
qui sont présentes ici merci beaucoup
toi mal vous restez avec nous reviendra
évidemment sur l'évolution de cette
situation nous sommes toujours avec
bruno attal président fondateur du
collectif touche pas à mon flic et
benoît talent quel regard est ce que
vous portez sur ce large dispositif
policier qui a été mise en place on
évoque quelques 4000 de son policiers et
gendarmes mobilisés
écoutez si la préfecture a jugé bon de
mettre quatre mille cinq cents policiers
c'est que ça l avait d information
probante pour dire que c'était ultra
dangereux mais toute façon vous voyez il
ya des manifestations la barre baisse
mais moi je me promenais tout à l'heure
dans paris et je peux vous dire que vous
avez pas mal de petits groupes qui
essaient de de semer le chaos à bloquer
les routes et donc voilà quatre mille
cinq cents policiers
c'est pas de trop je préfère qu'il y ait
beaucoup de policiers pour qu'on n'ait
pas de blessé et s'il ya des blessés en
face la main ça sera tant mieux pour eux
puisque l'on demande on nous demande de
toujours de faire attention à
l'intégrité physique de ces manifestants
qui sont hors la loi puisque cette
manifestation a été interdite
donc voilà j'espère que les quatre mille
cinq cents policiers j'espère qu'on
n'aura pas de blessés
de notre côté parce que c'est nous qui
sommes dans le droit et ces gens là qui
sont illégaux tout simplement le
couvre-feu aura lieu dans quelques trois
quarts d'heure 19h10 et là
mot d'ordre sera donné de dispersés
définitivement tous les manifestants
mais le mot d'ordre de disperser les
manifestants depuis le début
et ces gens là qui sont un vrai
réfractaires comment vos lois de la
république
je ne pense pas qu'ils vont se disperser
parce que c'est qu'on veut si ils
manifestent alors que c'est interdit et
ne respectent pas les lois de la
république
donc vous pensez qu'ils respectent le
couvre-feu en général toute façon bon
j'ai eu des renseignements de mes
collègues qui me disent non ce sont
beaucoup de racaille des cités qui sont
descendus pour mettre le chaos
et ces gens là toute façon mais respecte
pas le couvre feu non plus alors sur les
matches qu'on voit là beaucoup de deux
jeunes gens pacifiques jusque là vous
évoquez des racailles de ces thèmes est
ce que vous ne consommez pas qu'il
puisse y avoir des manifestants qui sont
là surtout et avant tout pour apporter
leur soutien au peuple palestinien
alors je ne pense pas qu'ils apportent
leur soutien au peuple palestinien je
pense qu'ils amènent la haine d'israël
la haine de la république puisqu'il ne
respecte pas vos vous dites qu'ils sont
pacifistes de madame mais le pacifiste
ils sont hors la loi il faut les images
qu'on voit là à l'état ils font quelque
chose d'illégal
vous dites ils sont pacifistes mais mes
collègues ont reçu des projectiles mais
ne me dites pas qu'ils sont pacifistes
et puis encore une fois pacifiste ça
veut dire qu'on respecte public madame
donc ils ne sont pas pacifiste en
esclave ni de l'intérieur qui est à
l'initiative de cette interdiction de
manifester à paris est ce qu il a pris
le bonne décision est ce que c'était la
bonne stratégie
évidemment puisque il y aurait eu
beaucoup plus de monde il y aurait
certainement eu de vrais gens pacifistes
qui respectent les lois de la république
et donc c'est très difficile dans une
manifestation de voir qui est le comble
et le congrès de mauvais grand et donc
effectivement c'est les gens qui sont
présents là ne respectent pas les lois
de la république donc si il n'y a que du
mauvais gras et en en interdisant cette
manifestation effectivement on voit que
de mauvais grande gueule mais un
rassemblement mars et qui a été
autorisée puisque les services de
renseignement
en lui les informations tout simplement
que ça se passera bien à marseille nous
avons à paris on a affaire aux mêmes la
population qui qui déteste la police
qu'il est derrière ce que ce soit dans
les cités ou dans ce genre de
manifestation et ça a cassé tout à
l'heure et vous verrez que sa carrière
sera encore et à ce que vous comprenez
justement que la manifestation était
interdite à paris mais autorisée dans de
nombreuses autres villes en france
mais pour preuve regardez ce qui se
passe en langue rose est en train de
vous dire que ces gens là serait violent
et je vais traiter des projets de chine
parce qu'elle est interdite mais il ya
sept ans elle était autorisée et ça les
a pas empêchés de crier mort aux juifs
de s'attaquer à des synagogues et de
mettre le chaos dans paris donc ces gens
là il ya sept ans ce sont les mêmes qui
sont ici ils n'ont pas disparu de la
voie publique du jour au lendemain donc
ce sont des haineux qui détestent israël
qui détestent l'occident qui déteste la
police qui déteste le drapeau français
qui déteste les lois de la république et
le prouve
il le prouve là sous mes yeux quand on
voit quand on voit si rassemblement
encore une fois interdit et on va faire
réagir à présent notre éditorialiste
nicolas vidal
nicolas quel regard est ce que vous
portez sur cette mobilisation parisienne
oui bonjour ce fils qui manque d'en haut
on peut noter déjà effectivement que il
ya une impossibilité de la part de la
préfecture de police de paris
d'interdire la manifestation puisque les
gens manifestement se sont regroupés
alors je sais pas combien ils sont
exactement sur quel secteur it so mais
après bon il ya ce premier point
ensuite après bombay ça peut poser aussi
les questions effectivement des
interactions manifester et cela pose des
questions de philosophie politique vous
savez libertés fondamentales et puis
troisième élément de réponse rapidement
sophie je vous le dis comme je le pense
la question qui se pose dans cette
manifestation dans ces manifestations de
soutien au peuple palestinien
c'est l'importation de nos conflits
étrangers sur notre sol moi c'est ça qui
me pose en question la question de fond
qui dessous c'est ça il est assez
récurrent en france mais l'a finalement
en l'état français que peut-il
aujourd'hui sur ce conflit israélo
palestinien si la question qui se pose
ça fait plusieurs années que beaucoup de
puissances s'affrontent arrive pas bien
entendu à régler ce problème donc si je
me pose tous la question moi de cette
importation des cons qui vous voyez
puis pour une fois je suis d'accord une
fois n'est pas coutume je suis d'accord
des guerriers natale
voilà moi ce qui m'inquiète
l'importation de conflits sur notre sol
et je crois qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de
preneurs régler et très sincèrement
voilà comment je cadre on peut cette
question là on est pas inévitable
justement est-ce qu'elle n'est pas
inévitable importations de ce conflit en
france
ben le problème c'est que j'ai envie de
vous répondre à moi je poste des
théories des hypothèses je suis un
éditorialiste
mais on dirait qu'il ya une libanisation
aujourd'hui notre société de notre
communauté nationale et aisselles et là
nous avons des gens effectivement qu'ils
viennent manifester pour des causes qui
sont souvent très éloignés pour
certaines la france et sur le théâtre
d'opérations mais pour d'autres c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
de sorte qu'elle confie israël aux
palestiniens je le répète encore ça fait
des années des décennies que ce problème
se pose entre israël et les palestiniens
est aujourd'hui qu'est ce que peut faire
la france dans ce conflit là ça ne tient
pas qu'à emmanuel macron donc c'est pour
ça que moi je m'inquiète toujours il ya
encore plus maintenant sophie encore
plus maintenant parce que moi cette
libanisation de notre pays de notre
unité nationale de l'allégeance et la
communauté nationale finalement elle
prend de plus en plus d'ampleur et c'est
assez inquiétant ce manifestation en
l'occurrence celle ci car est ce que
vous vous portez sur l'apostolat france
sur les récentes déclarations d'
emmanuel macron oui mais moi ce que je
regarde surtout j'ai un regard on va
dire sur le long terme je parle de
décénnie
bien entendu aujourd'hui comment quel
est le levier diplomatique pour pouvoir
un moment donné essayer de régler ces
problèmes le confient les complexes
sincèrement et je vous le dis je suis
allé à quelques mois de ça en israël
notamment bande de gaza jusqu'à kerem
shalom et je me suis rendu compte de
check point qui est vraiment au sud
d'israël entre le sinaï l'egypte la
bande de gaza et israël
et on se rend compte une fois sur place
que c'est extrêmement complexe donc la
place de la france ce n'est pas que la
place de la fin ce n'est pas que le
levier que doit activer la france c'est
la communauté nationale qui dans son
mensonge qui dans son ensemble se casse
les dents sur ce conflit là d'ailleurs
on se rend compte aussi que la palestine
a perdu des années notamment vis à vis à
vis l'egypte l'arabie saoudite donc tous
ces
les plaques tectoniques géostratégique
géopolitique très complexe et très
sincèrement aujourd'hui le sens de l'art
et de la communication aussi une
manifestation de soutien pourquoi pas
mais aujourd'hui le problème très très
complexe et je lui redis je vous le
redis pour moi c'est manifestement une
importation dans koh phi très éloignées
sur notre sol et je crois que la france
a déjà beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes
pour ne pas même porté d'autre est de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu doux doute
quelque chose qui coûteront soir voilà
c'est aussi l'europe doit se positionner
sur le conflit au proche orient
aujourd'hui vie si vous aviez une
diplomatie européenne sophie si vous
aviez une diplomatie européenne je vous
encourage je vous renvoie au rendez-vous
d'ursula von der leyen et de charles
michel à ankara en turquie devant recep
erdogan
mais il faudrait que l'union européenne
est et pour sa diplomatie
et pour avoir une diplomatie vous savez
que c'est le propre de lempire qu'il a
le nom qu'il ya des vassaux d'aider sa
passion et je ne crois pas aujourd'hui
que l'union européenne est une
diplomatie une vision claire nette et
globale et massive de ces problèmes là
donc ça posera toujours en sous main on
va me dire encore que je par l'union
européenne mais plus que vous me posez
la question je réponds et beaucoup
plaisir mais il s'impose 3 le problème
de la force politique que représente
l'union européenne et aujourd'hui je
crois que sur les théâtres d'opération
et sur la diplomatie
la france n'avait encore il ya quelques
temps vous savez de voix qui porte et et
je profite le moins en moins le cas donc
ça pose une question pour ça vraiment
très large très large triglobal enfin et
alors sur la manifestation parisienne
qui a donc été interdite par le
ministère de l'intérieur par la
préfecture de police de paris
est-ce que c'était la bonne stratégie
visiblement il n'a pas empêché les
protestataires à se rassembler cet après
midi je vous le disais vous disais faire
dans le sujet une présentation 4300
forces de l'ap de nos policiers qui sont
allés sur le terrain bien entendu
associé au brave m notamment et bien
effectivement les organisateurs ils ont
défié la préfecture de police de paris
là dessus donc ça c'est toujours c'est
toujours compliqué pour un état pour une
préfecture finalement notre désavoué sur
une interdiction l'a dit aussi c'était
pas souvent la tribune à mr hâtif qui a
aussi dit la médiation soit interdite
donc là on est vraiment finalement les
organisateurs en quelque sorte ont défié
la préfecture de police de paris et j'ai
trouvé la préfecture plus de paris
souvent bien moins sympathique avec
certaines magnifie les gens du début
voyez-vous où certaines correct et mené
après sommes carrément été interdite il
n'y a rien qui s'est passé donc s'impose
aussi toutes ces questions et je le
disais tout à l'heure ça pas aussi des
questions libertés fondamentales de
manifester de revendiquer et donc c'est
vraiment point de très larges et ces
manifestations il faut les voir avec un
peu de hauteur de vue me semble-t-il
pour essayer de comprendre mais très
sincèrement le problème reste entier et
vous direz que les tensions étaient
inévitables on a vu ces affrontements
entre alliés manifestants cet après midi
et les forces de l'ordre alors ça ce
jour pareil devant l'europe des
manifestations qui deviennent de plus en
plus violente on le voit au fil dès
samedi le foie pour tout près tous les
manifestations vous avez des
groupuscules qui sont à des
manifestations
on espère toujours bien entendu que un
maximum de manifestants viennent là
paisiblement pour manifester sur
maintenant un intervenant le disait dans
nos reportages micro-trottoir bien
entendu mais vous avez toujours de plus
en plus des groupuscules qui se met dans
les manifestations qui viennent créer le
trouble qui viennent semer le trouble
qui sont extrêmement violent qui sont là
pour le défaut de l'ordre public et ça
c'est de plus en plus compliqué ces
moments de plus en plus conquis team
mais c'est toujours pareil la
composition de manifestations alors
cette manifestation a été maintenue par
les organisateurs une trentaine
d'associations qui ont malgré
l'interdiction appelait à se rassembler
on les a très peu vu finalement sur les
images ses organisateurs ben oui me
semble-t-il alors j'ai pas fait tous les
jets passer tous les images de plusieurs
prix me dit mais finalement oui le
dimanche vous montrer notamment sur arte
france oui on est on y voit très peu
mais une nouvelle fois sa pause voilà
c'est moi cette manie station me pose
vraiment la question pose vraiment la
question essentielle de l'importation
non confie la tuer je crois qu'à un
moment donné la france aujourd'hui n'a
pas besoin on n'a pas besoin de mettre
de l'huile sur le feu dans ce pays qui
est déjà extrêmement fracturée et moi ça
me pose la question de la libanisation
aussi de ce pays la communauté qui
manifestent pour découvrir les traits du
tueur mais c'est ça pour moi qui me qui
m'inquiète énormément voilà sept
libanisation de la france qui est en
train de fracturer petit à petit pour ça
et pour d'autres choses mais entendu on
l'a vu ces dernières semaines vick terry
chat
l'élève des généraux les veines des
mini-terrains active maintenant la
lettre d'un ancien policier
on voit bien que tout ça un espèce de
fil rouge qui est de plus en plus
inquiétants et se figeront est en train
d'être tendu tendu tendue est ce qu'un
jour il va pas casser c'est sincèrement
je ne l'espère pas merci beaucoup aux
nicolas vidal éditorialiste a su arte
france merci également à bruno heppell
président fondateur du collectif touche
pas à mon flic vous étiez avec nous à
l'instant on va faire désormais le point
sur la situation au proche orient malgré
les efforts régionaux pour obtenir un
cessez-le-feu les tirs de roquettes du
hamas et les raids aériens de l'armée
israélienne continue ce samedi une
frappe israélienne a ciblé l'immeuble
d'une dizaine des tâches qui abrite les
locaux de la chaîne de télévision
qatarie al jazeera et l' agence de
presse américaine associated press
garantir la sécurité des médias est
capital a réagi cet après midi la maison
blanche à l'attention d'israël
cette nuit ce sont dix membres d'une
même famille qui ont été tués toujours
dans la bande de gaza lors d'un raid
parmi les victimes huit enfants et deux
femmes l'armée israélienne a indiqué que
des équipements militaires du hamas le
mouvement islamiste au pouvoir dans
l'enclavé palestinienne se trouvaient
dans la tour frappés par ces avions de
combat selon notre correspondante paula
slayer qui se trouve tout près la
frontière entre territoires palestiniens
israël l'armée israélienne souhaite
continuer de nettoyer gaza comme l
affirme
les israéliens ont déjà détruit de
nombreuses plateformes de lancement de
roquettes qui pourrait conduire deux
fêtes à une désescalade des violences
une désescalade qui est évoqué pour les
prochains jours il sera expliqué essayer
de nettoyer en juin à l'occasion c'est à
dire je détruire autant de plateformes
de lancement de roquettes
autant imier lieux occupés par le masque
possible vendredi cinq ans
lancement à gaza ont été détruites et
donc effectivement on commence à parler
de désescalade dans les journées à venir
mais c'est difficile à dire
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la situation sur le terrain alors ils se
retrouvent un samedi après-midi en
général dans la rue afin de se passer
andy agréable et bien tous les magasins
sont fermés et il n'y a personne dans
les rues six mois par la police
les tanks et les journalistes les gens
restent chez eux ils sont peur côté
palestinien de nouvelles roquettes ont
été tirées qui ont direction d'israël la
plupart détruite par le dôme de fer
système de défense aérien israélien
le conflit a déjà coûté la vie à au
moins 139 palestiniens en neuf morts
côté israélien les autorités
israéliennes ont annoncé poursuivre
leurs opérations
le hamas a commis une grave erreur en
décidant de tirer sur l'état d'israël
l'armée israélienne répond par une
attaque au cours de laquelle nous
opérons sur la base de plans préparés
il y à d'autres étapes prête à être
engagés nous frappons avec une force
significative qui prend de multiples
facettes et c'est un coup dur pour les
capacités de production d'armes du hamas
et du jihad islamique palestinien
cela leur prendra beaucoup de temps pour
se reconstruire et dans ce contexte des
centaines de gazaouis ont fui les lieux
certains se sont abrités dans des écoles
des écoles gérées par le programme des
assauts des nations unies pour les
réfugiés de palestine beaucoup
traumatisés par les bombardements
nous étions assis lorsque les
bombardements ont commencé
la maison trembler et les enfants
hurlaient et le feu s'est déclaré
partout la fenêtre est tombé sur les
enfants et dieu merci ils ont survécu
les maisons sont touchées par les bombes
il cible les maisons avec des résidents
à l'intérieur de la bande de gaza le
conflit s'étend désormais à la
cisjordanie mais aussi aux villes mixtes
d'israël situation ton but entre juifs
et arabes israéliens affrontements dont
la rue parfois violents thomas bonnin
des scènes d'affrontements parfois d'une
extrême violence
sous le regard impuissant des forces de
l'ordre israéliennes depuis plusieurs
jours des villes mixtes en israël sont
le théâtre d'importantes tensions
communautaires et puissante et des
phénomènes
la ville de lod situe à quelques
kilomètres de tel aviv
d'un côté des juifs ultranationalistes
de l'autre des arabes israéliens
chacun s'accuse ans d'être à l'origine
des provocations
après les trois dernières soirées nous
ne sortions plus nous savions que nous
ne pouvions pas sortir parce que les
arabes étaient là ils se rassembler en
groupes et commencer à nous jeter des
pierres et à brûler nos affaires
les colons sont venus vers les
habitations et ont cassé des fenêtres
ils ont essayé de rentrer ils ont fait
peur à ma femme et à mes enfants
ils ont brûlé les voitures ici pour
tenter de contenir la violence dans la
ville
et face aux stigmates encore visibles
des heurts de ces derniers jours comme
cette synagogue qui a été incendié
les autorités israéliennes ont annoncé
le déploiement de renforts massifs dans
les villes mixtes du pays l'état
d'urgence a également été décrété à lod
mais signe que la fracture est profonde
il n'ya pas seulement ces affrontements
il y a aussi des agressions ciblées sur
ces images de vidéosurveillance un juif
est attaquée à jérusalem ici une foule
d'ultranationalistes linchamps chauffeur
arabe dans une banlieue de tel aviv
la scène a été diffusé en direct à la
télévision
j'ai une situation d'anarchie
selon les mots du premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou qu'il
qualifie même de deuxième front après
celui qui oppose israël au hamas aux
citoyens d'israël jeudi que je me fiche
que votre sang bouillonne vous ne pouvez
pas vous faire justice vous même vous ne
pouvez pas venir et prendre un citoyen
arabe et essayer de le lyncher
tout comme on ne peut pas voir des
citoyens arabes faire cela des citoyens
juifs
rémy on dit alors un peu plus d'un tiers
des habitants de cette ville moyenne et
arabes cela fait des décennies qu'il
cohabite de manière relativement
paisible avec leurs concitoyens juifs au
gré des conflits mais depuis plusieurs
années cette ville pauvre a vu arriver
de plus en plus de sionistes religieux
alors la menace d'expulsion de
palestiniens à jérusalem est ravivé la
crainte qui existent aussi dans cette
ville du centre d'israël
résultats des groupes souvent jeunes se
radicaliser s'affrontent
la situation inquiète les autorités
politiques et religieuses et malgré les
appels au calme répéter les discours
belliqueux du hamas et de netanyahu ont
des répercussions très directe dans les
rues des villes mixtes israélienne et de
nombreux invités se sont relayés toute
la journée sur notre antenne pour
commenter cette actualité parmi eux
claire et offre porter écrivant et
riccardo bocco spécialiste du
moyen-orient
en revanche il s'agit d'une il s'agirait
il du débordement avec un soutien à une
organisation terroriste
or lisation terroristes palestiniennes
qui le ramasse qu'il nous arrosent de
roquettes depuis lundi ont des requêtes
qui sont vos licences à la ville et sur
toutes les villes israéliennes
ce ne sont pas des feux d'artifice il ya
des blessés il ya des morts il ya des
habitations détruites
il ya trois jours on a été réveillés
quatre fois pendant la nuit avec elle
des explosions elle des sirènes
on est dans une situation où pour sortir
de l'impasse
il faudrait imposer à l'état il ya de
renoncer à une série de politiques comme
celle de la colonisation pour commencer
pour ne pas parler de la nécessité à
moyen terme de évacuer les colonies pour
laisser la place à la population
palestinienne d'évoluer sur différents
plans y compris les plats national
social et culturel mais également
économique parce que
l'économie palestinienne est
pratiquement otage de l'économie
israélienne
effectivement il ya des enfants
palestiniens qui sont morts et c'est
très regrettable
il faut savoir qu'ils sont conservés
comme bouclier humain en heure hamas il
faut savoir que 20 % 20 % des requêtes
du ramasse ont relié sur israël ils en
ont relié 2002 puis depuis lundi 20 %
tombe à l'intérieur de gaza sont des
dégâts tue des enfants et tu
certainement plus en tant que l'israël
non tu pour la simple raison qu israël
très bien avant chaque frappe aérienne
tant qu'il n'y aura pas un point sur la
table qui dise stop à la colonisation
pour commencer ce temps pas différent
autre chose
israël continuera mais ce qui est
dramatique dans tout ça c'est pas
simplement une question de soutien aux
palestiniens
c'est que on voit la société israélienne
s'enfoncer d'année en année dans le
cancer de la colonisation et avant de
refermer ce journal retour sur la
mobilisation parisienne en soutien au
peuple palestinien en quelques centaines
de manifestants ont bravé l'interdiction
de la préfecture de police de paris
face à eux mobilisé quelques 4000 200
policiers et gendarmes
un mot d'ordre disperser les
protestataires face à face tendu cet
après midi les forces de l'ordre ont
fait usage de canons à eau et gaz
lacrymogènes
on trouve tout c'est notre reporter
thomas gonnet quelle est la situation
actuellement les tensions sont retombées
les tensions sont un peu retombés en
fait on voit les forces de l'ordre qui
sont ici on a dû ce recul est un petit
peu parce qu'il y avait un nuage de gaz
lacrymogène donc c'était compliqué on va
essayer d'avancer un petit peu
maintenant
merci monsieur donc la voilà la
situation est un peu redescendue en
tension parce que les manifestants qui
étaient stationnées ici porte de
clignancourt sont plus vraiment présent
forces de l'ordre ont vraiment gagné du
terrain et sont disposés en très grand
nombre tout à l'heure vous voyez vous
l'avez vu on était dans le dispositif
des gendarmes notamment qui ont donc
chargé à nombreuses reprises et
maintenant voilà la rue est débarrassé
des manifestants qui sont un peu plus
loin vers la porte de clignancourt on
voit encore des petits feux qui sont en
train d'être éteint il ya les pompiers
qui sont en intervention injuste jusque
là bas voilà pour une situation qui est
un peu revenue au calme
il ya encore des manifestants toutefois
un port de clients qu il encore des
manifestants même qui sont ici mais la
situation n'est plus aussi tendues que
tout à l'heure même si on entend
régulièrement des tirs de gaz
lacrymogène qui sont envoyées voyez vous
l'entendez à l'instant par les forces de
l'ordre on a vu également la brave en
intervention tout à l'heure pour
disperser la foule
voilà donc pour la situation ici
boulevard ornano près de la porte de
clignancourt
merci beaucoup thomas et on vous
retrouve tout à l'heure à 19h pour notre
prochain journal c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve donc dans une trentaine
de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
tous
nous
[Musique]
le kremlin de toul a été érigée au 16e
siècle à l'époque des incursions des
tatars et des peuples de crime et une
époque de féroces batailles et de
campagne militaire ici on défendre
héroïquement les abords de moscou dit
encore cinq siècles
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas seulement une
attraction touristique
à présent le kremlin de tous là l un des
musées les plus visités du pays et
conserve de nombreux secrets qu